this video is sponsored by the book
summary app blinkist use the link in the
description and you'll receive one free
week and 25 off a premium membership
deeply perplexed by the absurdities and
troubles of existence 19th century
theologian and philosopher soren
kierkegaard explored and wrote of
profound new ideas that would ultimately
challenge the way humanity thinks about
philosophy religion and psychology
considered by most to be the father of
existentialism his work examines themes
common to the school of thought prodding
mocking and attempting to resolve
falsities of tradition and convention
the inconsistency between people's true
selves and how they act in the world and
the despair and anxiety so entrenched in
it all
kierkegaard was born in 1813 in
copenhagen denmark as the youngest of
seven children to a very well-off family
early on in his life he was exposed to
philosophical thinking as his father was
very interested in philosophy himself
often reading and having conversations
related to it around young kirkergaard
in early adulthood he would go on to
study philosophy and theology at the
university of copenhagen here however he
would soon find himself disliking and
turning away from the historical and
philosophical works he was being exposed
to finding them often overly
intellectualized and incongruent with
how life is actually lived
what i really need to do he wrote is to
get clear about what am i to do not what
i must know
this assessment would ultimately define
the orientation in which kierkegaard
would direct his philosophical efforts
also arguably significant to this
orientation by age 22 five of his six
siblings had already passed away
engulfing his child and early adult life
with the unsettling shadow of tragedy
and transience reminding him five times
over that life is synonymous with
uncertainty and that the worst case
might be just around the corner
around and following this time of his
mid-twenties kicker guard began writing
at an immensely productive rate
producing many books during his lifetime
under various pseudonyms as well as his
own name before dying in 1855 at the age
of 42 likely from a horrible case of
spinal tuberculosis
in terms of his philosophical work one
of kierkegaard's most notable and
profound contributions the one that we
will be mostly focusing on here was what
he would term angst
in his book the concept of anxiety he
would describe this term as a particular
feeling of anxiety and dread not any
sort of anxiety disorder but rather the
underpinning existential anxiety that
pervades the entire human condition in
general
generally anxiety is the heightened
emotional response to a perceived threat
or challenge especially one that is
unknown or uncertain
and so anxiety of this existential sort
which moving forward will just be
referred to as anxiety is the response
to the threat challenge or fear of the
unknown and uncertainty of existence as
a whole
more specifically it is the feeling of
freedom and responsibility that one has
within this uncertainty
in the words of kierkegaard anxiety is
the dizziness of freedom
in every moment we are possessed by an
awareness of our freedom or at least the
sense of freedom to choose and be
accountable for how the nearly infinite
unknowns and possibilities of life
become known and real through our
choices and actions
but yet we are given very little if not
none of the insights and information
needed to do so properly
worse yet there is perhaps no way of
ever truly making decisions correctly in
the way we hope even when we do make
them so called correctly
in large part we are driven by our
anxiety to make choices that will
eliminate our anxiety but arguably if we
have lived and thought long enough about
this we realize we have and will remain
condemned to a life inescapably pervaded
by at least some form of it
it is as if we are always at an
intersection of the past and future
given a steering wheel a dashboard of
dials and a kill switch but not given a
break an accelerator a reverse gear a
map or a navigation system we are
continually forced to drive through the
world in this vehicle but the world is
covered in an immense thick fog
naturally we hope that in some
directions the ones we choose the fog
will clear
but it never does not completely at
least
anyone who really knows mankind might
say that there is not one single living
human being who does not despair a
little who does not secretly harbor an
unrest an inner strife a disharmony an
anxiety about an unknown something or
something he dare not even try to know
an anxiety about some possibility in
existence or an anxiety about himself
kierkegaard wrote
recognizing the inevitability of anxiety
and dread kierkegaard sought to make
sense and use of it despite how bleak
everything might sound up until this
point he didn't believe anxiety was
totally a bad thing rather he believed
anxiety was a necessary part of life and
our response to it was what made the
difference between a life lived fully
and a life of emptiness and despair
understandably the dizziness felt by
anxiety can often be paralyzing walking
forward while your head is spinning is
hardly ideal and so this feeling of the
freedom to choose and do anything in
life can sometimes keep us from choosing
or doing anything at all if we imagine
how the anxiety of a large intimidating
item on our to-do list might keep us
from ever getting to it the
anxiety-induced paralysis felt by the
to-do list that is our entire life one
with a deadline not yet revealed and the
consequence literally being our
existence is certainly understandable
but our head will never really stop
spinning and if we wish to achieve a
potentially more fulfilled life and
actualize who we really are and could be
we must not succumb to the inaction of
this anxiety
in order to retain any sense of power
over our life and derive any meaning of
self we must retain an ability to move
forward and act in the face of this
anxiety
moreover it is arguably this anxiety or
perhaps the source of this anxiety that
allows for any possibility of developing
and deriving a unique meaningful self at
all
without any possibility there would be
no anxiety but without anxiety there
would be no possibility
gigger suggested that in order to best
make use of anxiety and live well with
it the individual must pursue what he
would refer to as passion this could
take the form of things like a love a
creative endeavor a family personal
growth a career an ideology a belief and
so on what's important for kierkegaard
however is that one orients their
passions based on subjective truth in
other words truths that are deemed to be
true by the individual not truths with
which there is necessarily objective
merit or ultimate reason to ground them
in it is not purely a matter of
intellectualization but also a matter of
emotional subjective experience
the crucial thing is to find a truth
which is truth for me to find the idea
for which i am willing to live and die
kierkegaard wrote
the individual must discover their
subjective truth and then throw the full
weight of their being in its direction
committing to it fully regardless of
reason or intellectual certainty to do
something for the sake of itself to take
a leap of faith
often through conformity distractions
addictions and any other forms of
escapism individuals attempt to avoid
the anxiety and responsibility of their
existence by universally conforming to
the status quo one attempts to absolve
themselves from the responsibility of
their choices and by means of things
like substance abuse chasing social
status superficial action materialism
and so on one attempts to distract
themselves away from the fact that there
is no way to truly absolve themselves
for kierkegaard the development of self
is dependent on the ability to face up
to the anxiety of existence and move
with and through it
for him in an otherwise meaningless
existence this is where the meaning can
potentially be found
the consequences rather of succumbing to
anxiety and inaction for kicker guard is
much much worse it results in despair a
depressed apathetic state a failed lost
and unrealized self a frictional
experience of existence
in the words of modern psychoanalyst
james hollis anxiety is the price of the
ticket to life intrapsychic depression
is the byproduct of the refusal to climb
aboard
one must realize that life will never
become more sturdy or less scary there
will never be a perfect optimal time to
climb aboard if life is a sequence of
impossible decisions veiled by
uncertainty we might as well attempt to
justify it by at least making decisions
that pursue the greatest and most
interesting heights and depths of the
unknown we are capable of traveling
gigergard's framework and solution to
this problem was faith in the christian
god but his philosophy and some part can
arguably provide a premise that is
applicable to any subjective view of
meaning and purpose
especially nowadays anxiety is often
seen as something wrong and negative
a weakness or an illness but anxiety is
arguably a fundamental ingredient
entrenched in the experience of human
consciousness
to feel and to think is to be anxious
perhaps added to the list of terms we
ought to be called is homo anxietatum
anxious man
how could we not be anxious it is a
natural response to an intensely
disquieting confusing and uncertain
existence that we are given an
unrequested role in and the more choices
we garner access to in the modern world
we are only left with even more reasons
to fret and turn in anxiety over more
ways we hope we can quiet it as well as
more ways to feel responsible when we
inevitably don't
but we must like kicker guard suggested
try our best to learn how to live with
and through it to keep moving forward
into the unknown and take our leaps of
faith into what we truly and personally
believe makes it all worth living
and dying for
this video was sponsored by blinkist
savannah was a regular reader she
especially enjoyed learning about
psychology and cognitive science she
read about a book every month on these
subjects one of her closest friends
christine also shared in this interest
and routine with her at 20 years old
however savannah was introduced to the
book summary app blankist which
condenses over 5 000 non-fiction books
into around 15-minute summaries having
some of her favorite books on psychology
like outliers by malcolm gladwell why we
love by helen fisher and the social
animal by david brooks savannah decided
to give it a try right away she was able
to quickly refresh herself on key parts
of her favorite books like in outliers
she recalled how surprisingly
significant her date of birth is in
potentially affecting various
opportunities and conditions of her life
how her self-beliefs and self-confidence
influenced by her upbringing and culture
can make or break her success in
different subjects and how she can
better understand forgive and optimize
her unique set of circumstances to
orient herself towards success
savannah was hooked and she soon tried
convincing christine to try blinkist as
well however christine was skeptical and
a bit stubborn so she never did
over the following year christine
learned from about 10 books savannah
however using blinkist listened and read
summaries during her downtime her
commute while she did things around the
house and so on and so in the same year
christine read 10 books savannah learned
from 327 different books on blinkist and
spent less time than christine did
leaving her with enough additional time
to still read three and a half complete
books
not only that but as time continued
while christine remained stuck in mostly
the same subjects savannah had time to
explore the 27 categories blinkist
offers and discovered that she also had
a passion for history economics and
personal finance which all culminated
into a more versatile career and daily
life
if you're interested in making the same
decision savannah did blinkist is
available for you as well and if you use
the link in the description you'll
receive one free week of unlimited
access as well as 25 off a premium
membership the free 7-day trial can be
canceled at any time within the trial
period
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you next
video
you